YESTERDAY'S DEADLINE TO TURN
OVER THE MEMOS.
HERE WITH REACTION, HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
YOU KNOW, MY FIRST POINT IS
THIS, CONGRESSMAN.
I WATCHED THE INTERVIEW, AND I
WAS STUNNED.
IT TOOK MY BREATH AWAY.
AS JAMES COMEY TALKED ABOUT THE
HAPPENED, THE BULK OF
INFORMATION TO OBTAIN THAT
WARRANT TO SPY ON AMERICAN, AN
ASSOCIATE OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
IN AN ELECTION YEAR, WAS THE
DOSSIER, AND IF IT WASN'T FOR
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE, WE NEVER
WOULD HAVE LEARNED THAT, OR THE
GRASS THEY-GRANDMA THAT CAME
OUT.
DO YOU THINK -- WHAT DO YOU
THINK THAT MEANS ABOUT WHAT THEY
SAID TO A FISA COURT?
>> THE IRONY HERE IS QUITE
FRANKLY HARD TO BELIEVE.
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE THAT
MR. COMEY USES, LIKE HE SAYS, ,I
THINK HE SAID IT IS CERTAINLY
POSSIBLE THAT THE RUSSIANS HAD
INFORMATION ON TRUMP.
WELL, IT IS CERTAINLY POSSIBLE
THAT THE RUSSIANS COULD HAVE
INFORMATION ON COMEY.
IT IS CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT
THE RUSSIANS COULD HAVE
INFORMATION ON HILLARY CLINTON.
IT IS CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT
THEY HAVE INFORMATION ON ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE.
>> Sean: WHEN THAT DOSSIER,
WHICH MAY DIG UP THE BULK OF THE
FISA APPLICATION AT SUPPLICANT
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF I'
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IS
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IP
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF II
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IL
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF I,
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IA
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF ID
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF II
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IT
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IW
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IS
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF I'
FREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS, IF IT
VERIFIED AND WASN'T
CORROBORATED, AND YOU STILL
PRESENTED IT TO A JUDGE, AND
YOU NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR IT, BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR IT, AND IT WAS A
FOREIGN NATIONAL THAT PRINTED
SALACIOUS, UNPROVEN LIES FROM
RUSSIAN SOURCES, DID THEY LIE TO
A FISA COURT JUDGE, IN YOUR
OPINION?
>> BY NOT TELLING THE FISA
COURT, IT'S TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE.
THEY KNEW THE INFORMATION AND
THEY HAVE A DUTY AND OBLIGATION
TO TELL THE COURT EVERYTHING
THEY KNOW.
BUT SEAN, LET'S GO BACK TO WHEN
WE WERE FIRST BRIEFED ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
WE, CONGRESS.
SO WE HEARD, MR. COMEY'S
INTERVIEW WHAT HE SAID, WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REACTION WAS
TO LEARNING WHAT THE DOSSIER.
HE TALKED ABOUT WHY HE DIDN'T
TELL PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT IT WAS
PAID FOR BY HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
WELL, THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE IMPORTANT IN THIS, LIKE
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
I WAS IN THE MEETING WITH
SENATOR McCONNELL, SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE PAUL RYAN, AND MANY
OTHERS.
HE HAD AMPLE OPPORTUNITY IN
EARLY 2017 TO TELL US WHO PAID
FOR THE DOSSIER.
WE WERE BRIEFED ON THE DOSSIER.
I CAN TELL YOU, IF THEY WOULD
HAVE BROUGHT UP, IF THE FBI
WOULD HAVE PRESENTED TO US ON
THE DATE OF THIS INFORMATION WAS
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PART
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PART-
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTF
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTR
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTE
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PART
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTH
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTE
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTF
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTC
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTT
PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTA
IT WAS USED --
>> Sean: IT WASN'T VERIFIED.
>> IT WASN'T VERIFIED.
WE KNEW IT WASN'T VERIFIED AT
THE TIME BECAUSE THEY TOLD US IT
WASN'T VERIFIED.
BUT CAN YOU IMAGINE THE
REACTION?
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK I WOULD
HAVE SPENT UP WITH MY COFFEE AND
STARTED LAUGHING.
SECOND OF ALL, WE WOULD HAVE
WALKED OUT OF THERE AND SAID
WHAT IN THE HILL ARE YOU GUYS
DOING?
YOU ARE BRINGING A START THAT
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
PAID FOR?
YOU GUY'S BEEN USING THIS?
YOU ARE PRESENTING IT TO US AS
TO WHY YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
THAT IS LAUGHABLE.
>> Sean: HOW WAS THAT NOT
ILLEGAL, THOUGH?
I FEEL THIS IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE
OF POWER THAT I HAVE EVER SEEN
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE AND WHEN YOU
THEN GO BACK TO YOU, AND YOU SEE
THAT THESE SAME PLAYERS KEEP
COMING UP, AND IT WAS COMEY WITH
TRUMP HEATING PETER STRZOK, WE
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEX
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TET
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEM
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TES
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEA
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEE
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TE,
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEA
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TED
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEP
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TET
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TER
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TES
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEO
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE TEK
IS THE ONE ON INTERVIEWS
HILLARY, AND PETER STRZOK AND
JAMES COMEY ARE WRITING AN
EXONERATION AND MAY AND
THEY DON'T INTERVIEW HERE TILL
JULY, IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
INVESTIGATION WAS RIGGED.
>> OR YOU HAVE MR. COMEY
VOLUNTEERED THIS UP ON THE
INTERNET THE OTHER DAY.
HE SAID THAT THE FISA ON CARTER
PAGE, CARTER PAGE WAS IN THE
INITIAL REASON I STARTED THE
INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS PAPADOPOULOS.
OKAY.
HE WANTED TO INVESTIGATE
PAPADOPOULOS.
YOU HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
FOR YOUR VIEWERS, THAT WAS IN
JULY OF 2016.
WHY IS IT THAT YOU NEVER
BOTHERED TO TALK TO
MR. PAPADOPOULOS, BUT YOU DID
BOTHER TO GO AND GET A FISA
WARRANT ON MR. PAGE IN OCTOBER
OF '16?
YOU DON'T TALK TO
MR. PAPADOPOULOS UNTIL 2017?
WAIT A SECOND.
I THOUGHT PAPADOPOULOS WAS THE
REASON YOU STARTED THE
INVESTIGATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THESE ARE ALL UNANSWERED
QUESTION THAT KEEPS OWN RAVELING
WE HAVE TO KEEP FIGHTING BIT
BY BIT BY BIT.
>> Sean: WE NEED THE
INFORMATION.
THIS ALL NEEDS TO GO TO COURT
AND PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD IN